the Joe Rogan experience you see
Dolomites yet no I don't know again you
know you gotta watch these shits if I'm
gonna come on the show when Dolomites do
you see it when he's knowing you mean
the new wear fur stole a [ __ ] my our
boy stole the show our boy
the dude were you gonna [ __ ] MMA a
whistle sounds a [ __ ] movie okay bad
[ __ ] bad [ __ ] bad
[ __ ] I you know I'm sick and
tired evil gonna walk what happened to
him nothing happened to him well well
well what happened to David tell David
Tao is getting stronger every weekend
what you're looking at some [ __ ]
idiot jumping up and down on Netflix
David towel is getting stronger and
stronger when you go see David though
it's like people going crazy right now
about uncut gems [ __ ] Adam Sandler's
been around for 30 years he's got
something for your ass it may not be
goofy jumping up and down and wetting
here but when he did have you seen own
country Hertz great just go for him to
cheer him on to go you don't want thank
God because people think that we're like
[ __ ] mooks is commerce I hate you
from flop in 90 different directions you
could just axe [ __ ] we could do it all
and when we get 30 years under our belt
we become weapons like Jimmy Smits like
any of these people that have been doing
it for 30-plus [ __ ] years eventually
you're gonna get [ __ ] good at it yeah
so you know I still didn't see the
Tarantino movie I saw the Joker
Tarantino movie was amazing I saw I
won't say that a disrespect for Bruce
Lee I saw the joke I just don't even
want to go there with no I'm not going
if he didn't [ __ ] live through it I
don't want to hear his [ __ ] take on
it it's it's not it doesn't make sense
it disrespected Shannon so it means that
disrespected me you in you disrespected
my [ __ ] pal and now you know I mean
no Shannon Lee yeah well if a bunch of
these people got fired up I watched a
joker I liked it though the Joker was
intense
I like the Joker was intense I saw hunka
gems during the break I went to
Christmas night my [ __ ] girls went to
sleep so I slid over to the Laemmle ate
three edibles and my heart was beating
with that [ __ ] because that movies
Joey Diaz 83 to 84 whatever you want to
do we wanted to do what do you want to
do with your Rogan listen I got I got
something coming next week let me get 20
G's till next week there ain't no next
week Jamie don't say nothing orokin I
need tend to [ __ ] and put this number in
and it just goes taking your life from
there you borrow from Peter to pay Paul
and then you're telling hey Suz to suck
your dick
it's nonstop people were like don't get
high and go see it [ __ ] you I'm going
deep don't see it I'd prepare like a
table at huh who's in it just I'm saying
when a bunch of [ __ ] whatever's it's
just a movie of all the basketball
player that you don't know what a good
Kevin Garnett okay and it's it's nonstop
so it's mostly Sandler and it's bumping
into Oh what happened to my dirty
Wow I'll catch you next week I gotta go
yeah you [ __ ] you know it's
[ __ ] constant it's you know that life
and then it traumatic is an Academy
Award winner I don't [ __ ] know you
know I took it home I wore it for a
couple days it's okay there's anything
in the [ __ ] Academy award-winner
anymore
I watched the Irishman you're gonna see
it yet either so you know you're skiing
for three hours what are you doing these
flights you look at enn woods wait for
him to go to sleep then you go to sleep
you [ __ ] you yeah that's when I watch
these three hour movies I can't watch
them at home I got a seven-year-old on
flights
[Applause]